astronaut Buzz Aldrin is the second man
to have landed on the moon he is now 87
years old a real hero was the pilot on
the Apollo 11 lunar module a former US
Air Force officer with the prestigious
command pilot rating he was in orbit on
the Gemini 12 mission he did spacewalk
work for five hours on that mission pad
and he appeared to be in physical pain
while watching Donald Trump deliver a
bizarre and rambling speech about space
exploration this was at a press
conference at the White House to
celebrate Donald Trump signing of an
executive order remember when executive
orders were bad according to trump under
Obama now with Obama that was under
Obama yet now they're good under Donald
Trump he was signing an executive order
to revive the National Space Council I'm
going to play about a minute of this and
you'll see if you're watching along with
us you'll see Buzz Aldrin standing
behind Donald Trump looking initially
disgusted and ultimately in physical
pain at the incoherent rambling of Trump
on this issue very strongly about it I
felt strongly about it for a long time I
used to say before doing that I did I
used to say what happened why aren't we
moving forward today's announcement
sends a clear signal to the world that
we are restoring America's proud legacy
of leadership in space at some point in
the future we'll look back and say how
did we do it without space the vice
president will serve as the council's
chair the privatization of certain
aspects is going to be very is going to
play a very crucial role don't you think
they are truly into it I will say that's
not easy because everybody wants to be
on this board people that you wouldn't
have believed loved what we're doing so
much they want to be as some of the more
successful people in the world want to
be on this board the human soul yearns
for discovery by unlocking the mysteries
of the universe we are locked truths
within ourselves that's true our journey
into space will not happen so it's all
funny right bla bla yeah yeah yeah but
there's some seriously disturbing stuff
from Trump at this speech unjust
about every issue Trump has it not
slightly wrong but way wrong Donald
Trump during this press conference
focused on the importance of space
security
you know what space security is code for
crony capitalism space security means
things very serious things like
satellites used by the military to
monitor other countries maybe rocket
launches or troop movements whatever
that's not a bad thing in principle but
who provides most of that technology
it's companies like Lockheed Martin and
other contractors we're already seeing
space exploration become public
relations cover for the
military-industrial complex and crony
capitalism and if there's really a
reason for Buzz Aldrin to cringe here
it's not just that Donald Trump sounds
like a buffoon on this issue like with
every other issue
it's that Donald Trump is presenting a
degenerate vision of our space
exploration priorities that's the
problem you can see why Buzz Aldrin is
so fatigued here and you got at this a
little bit earlier but 66 combat
missions in Korea all the preparation
and quarantine that you need to prepare
yourself for the Apollo 11 space mission
right punching that conspiracy theorist
in the face he had to go through all of
that but nothing could prepare him for
this Trump's we're having to stand
behind Donald Trump it reminds me of the
chris Christie debacle remember this
when Chris Christie ended up standing
behind Donald Trump after his failed
president a presidential run ended and
as you see on his face here he ended up
standing behind Donald Trump during a
press conference and Trump saying
bizarre and loony thing after thing and
Chris Christie looking sort of like he
had bad clams Casino about an hour and a
half prior to the press conference
that's what all buzz aldrin reminded me
of right I mean you can see why the
Golden State Warriors the defending NBA
champions don't want to go to the White
House because they don't want to go
through that did we ever figure out what
the official reason that they're not
going is I have an update on them yeah
we're going after a Pat's going to look
into that for us okay to put a fine
point on how absurd this entire thing
was check out this bizarre moment when
the actual signing of the executive
order took place
and the awesomes infinity could be
something but it could be infinity right
yeah okay so because you might not have
heard that the White House released a
transcript of what was said there and
we're going to put it up on the screen
for you
Buzz Aldrin said infinity and beyond and
of course people laugh because that's
that's a phrase from a Star Trek boy
story from toys and no character in that
is Buzz Lightyear Buzz Lightyear is all
about driving very good okay honey so
Donald Trump then says this is infinity
here it could be infinity we don't
really know but it could be it has to be
something but it could be infinity right
okay
what on earth is wrong with Donald Trump
I mean that this is an ill individual
there is no other explanation for what
is going on with this guy and Buzz
Aldrin placed there like he is in a
different universe for lack of a better
term and just completely understandable
distraught by Donald Trump's behavior I
mean we don't expect Donald Trump to be
an expert on Science and Technology and
faith and to know all the terminology
but I think that's all the more reason
to stick to the teleprompters when
you're giving one of these speeches and
this might be infinity we don't know but
it could be can anyone parse that for us
or is Shawn splice you're going to tell
us a select group of people knew exactly
what the president meant by that okay
send me your thoughts about this we are
on Facebook at facebook.com slash David
Pakman show we'll take a break we'll try
to regain our composure here in studio
and be back after this